[Music]
in Hawker theft news Oh someone a hacker
got theft today I guess so or they used
hacking to thieving oh man submitted by
JK is the first and the last Hey beside
a rider
Nigerians have the sales deal between
two Ford dealerships stealing over
$700,000 while they're up in their game
you know oh no more Craigslist
no more Nigerian prince yeah are they
getting better internet connection out
there now or like have you ever seen
those like scam offices it's pretty it's
pretty funny because it's like you have
like this village right where some of it
is kind of like brick building and some
of them are still like huts and [ __ ] and
then the guys go into office like they
don't know some of them don't know that
this is like shady [ __ ] that they're
doing but they have like business suits
with like sandals on it's all mismatched
it [ __ ] yeah it's pretty I don't know it
is just interesting so the seller it was
in Ohio and it was for the beau town
said Ford dealership Oh
bold leadership the buyer is in Indiana
and it was the dawn hence Ford
dealership Downs hands full work
dealership I'm just gonna refer to them
as Byron's other
floor defined from Ford yes is everybody
from my training course gave me a Ford
Raptor if you give me a Ford Flex the
self guy in Ohio was looking to
negotiate a bulk vehicle sale with the
Ford dealer in Indiana and so they had
made deals before so we conducted this
entire transaction through email the
deal was for 20 vehicles valued at seven
hundred and thirty six thousand dollars
the Nigerians ended up hacking the
sellers email account so once the deal
was settled all incoming emails from the
buyer were filtered from the sellers
email and then rerouted to the Nigerian
the Nigerian hackers oh the hackers then
began to respond from a gmail account
with the sellers name wholesale the
buyer proposed to pay by cheque the
hackers responded with wire transfer
instructions instead and so he should
have known though that they'd been doing
checks because they've been doing work
together before it's also out data so if
they
one of the cheeks no no but I'm saying
it's like they've been doing the same
transactions and business together that
they should keep the payments the same
but it's also outdated so if they do
change it makes sense
all of a sudden 700 grand he wants to do
a wire transfer
what checks is like it is yeah I know I
agree with you
but like just all of a sudden they
change their payment plan like that
should be a red flag that's what you're
saying yeah yeah aren't they on speaking
terms like can they just call and be
like hey great what's up so the buyer
are saying that they didn't find it
strange you know that now that they're
requesting a wire transfer because the
dealers often use DBAs to conduct
transactions so to him or to them it was
normal and so the wire transfers were
sent to the hackers and then the buyer
began picking up the vehicles and
batches so a week later the seller
reaches out to the buyer to find out
where the money is and then everyone
started freaking out because they were
like what the hell you didn't get the
money like where'd the money go so in
the cellar for some odd reason ends up
suing the buyer for the non-payment of
the 24 vehicles so then now it was an
entire debate sparked as to who is
responsible in this entire mess
insurance and so the court said both
parties were negligent in their business
practices because the seller should have
maintained a more secure email system
and taken quicker action upon learning
that he might have been compromised and
the buyer should have ascertained that
an actual agent of Beau Townsend Ford
was requesting that it send money by
wire transfer so they should have
double-checked they're saying the seller
blamed the buyer by pointing out that
the emails head obvious spelling and
grammatical mistakes
and then the court responded by stating
recent emergence of voice-to-text
technology that could have easily been
claimed they're so forgiving I mean just
because someone has grammatical errors I
don't feel alike yeah that's what the
court didn't really take that the court
was not sympathetic to either side but
ultimately sided with the seller saying
that the contract was valid and the
buyer took delivery but didn't pay the
seller and so the seller deserves its
money she did pay the seller he didn't
know he did not because the seller
doesn't have the money even I'd really
impacted well that was this I don't know
that just doesn't sound right to me the
seller should go to insurance for that
money because he got that money stolen
technically it's not the responsibility
of the buyer though what do you mean
so the the seller he's the one that sent
the money right no the buyer sent the
money yeah duh cuz he's buying what the
[ __ ] they got all [ __ ] up in the
middle right right and that's why the
judge is saying well he's gonna be hard
on his ass and saying well dude like you
should have been way more careful by the
exchanges happen you just did I mean you
just channeled the money the wrong way
so you [ __ ] up so I think now it's
just the buyer that should go to the
insurer so you're saying but that dude
still either has to get his money back
or give back all the merch the seller
has to follow clean with insurance
because a buyer he has all the stuff and
he sent the money out right as isola
doesn't have this stuff so he needs to
make the claim yeah
the seller needs to make the claim
because the buyer sent the money in it
was his email that got breached so for
example let's say we're paying phone
bills right to whatever company that we
have service with let's say that their
email gets breached and then we get like
an official email from Verizon or Sprint
or whatever saying that we need to
switch payment because of whatever
whatever reason and sign up here we sign
up and then
they go where's the payment is like what
are you talking about
you guys got breached this is your
security flaw it's like Equifax is
that's happening on Equifax right now
where it's like we had nothing to do
with you know any of that day gap
reached their security was flawed so why
is it the person who got fooled and why
is it their fault you know I mean like
yeah it doesn't feel right it just feels
weird but he technically delivered the
money to him right and then even though
he didn't pay for that inventory
directly it's in his possession should
he just give back the inventory and then
request for insurance like which side
should request for insurance well if the
buyers already have the inventory then
the sellers can call the cops and say
they stole all my [ __ ] the by solder
[ __ ] yeah that's not the case because
they haven't made that call to the cops
so they didn't steal their [ __ ] we're
just saying that they did pay for this
[ __ ] oh okay okay so the buyer has to
call the cop and then get money insured
because he got scammed yeah that's
awesome
and then the seller has to call the cops
and sit and say he got scammed through
his email so his claim is not he lost
inventory because he has to deliver the
car so he asked they both have to make
the claim so he has a gave the car back
yeah yeah I was saying that the that the
buyer shouldn't have to get it then we
bought our house there's like two or
three assurance are we in the same [ __ ]
I never understood why so they both need
to call their own insurance at this
point so the buyer part calls owner
shares plus FDIC right is that what it
is I don't know if fjc applies in this
situation it's only checks or I don't
know bank only though like like if it's
your money
and it's you're the one moving it F
seriously doesn't apply to you it's like
if if it's your bank that's housing that
money and then the something happens
breach or whatever then it's
I see that's [ __ ] crazy yeah cuz then
how's the house this cellar even gonna
know that like it it just it's just it's
a [ __ ] up situation for both because
it's like how can that guy even say like
yeah we'll give you back inventory and
really believe that you did get hacked
or whatever you know yeah yeah you
should keep it it sucks
this is a [ __ ] up situation so when it
comes to law enforcement right like on
the cellar side he calls the law
enforcement because he's like I got
hacked
I need hacker Patrol or whatever the
other side is I got scammed I need to
first contact my bank and all that stuff
and then the law enforcement has to
contact Nigerian police or whatever or
the bank engineer international cyber
police yeah he has it's hard because
like what can happen if the Nigerians if
the banking system works like that in
Nigeria so basically the money gets
wired once it gets released I don't know
what their security system is but if
they have a history of like receiving
big payments this way then it shouldn't
raise any red flags what they do is they
go out get a cashier's check get the
money out they could have opened the
account under like a fake alias now the
money's gone
so now whatever's happening in the u.s.
finally goes back to Nigeria they try to
take that money out but it's like just
too late who are you gonna get it from
it's kind of like a money order huh they
just check it right away that's what
they would do at our bank all the time
like they would get it wired and if it
if the account checks out like yeah they
usually get this stuff there's nothing
shady going on get a cashier's check
that's cash people gotta be careful man
there's so much [ __ ] going on
I'm kind of glad chase blocked my wire
because I had to call them and go
through like three verifications and it
was kind of annoying but then hearing
this kind of [ __ ] I'm like I'm glad that
they they try they protect themselves
first before you for sure you know
because that's the money that's in their
system that's circulating that they're
investing so they're like no we're
covering our ass and only have a [ __ ]
about Joe like we got to make sure we
don't lose this money hey guys thanks
for watching that last episode did you
love it I know you did but guess what
you can also follow us on our personal
social media accounts with the links in
the description box below so go follow
all of us now to watch more videos check
out
[Music]
Oh